Well the answer is, we want to call this Car function in
the same context as the new Van instance that's been created right there.
Since that's being stored in the parameter this, we can just pass this along and
run the Car function in the same context as the Van function is being called.
We can get rid of this pretend line of code because it was only there
to remind us what was going to take place as a result of using the keyword new.
This is exactly how we want to call the Car function from within the Van
function such that it operates on the right context.
But people seem to find this line of code extremely confusing.
So let's take a look at it for a moment.